[Music]
jeez i can't believe we found a version
of earth with a ball fondler's movie
franchise even this early in the series
i find it impossible to believe that
morty could be surprised by much of
anything they find considering all the
insane adventures they've been on to
this point also they choose ball
fondlers over french toast i can't speak
to either movie's quality but i can
attest to the fact that ball fondling is
so much better after helping a french
toast or so i've heard allowing full
house to exist in more than one reality
what's wrong is it the quantum
carburetor or something jesus morty you
can't just add a sci-fi word to a car
word and hope it means something over
800 episodes of star trek would beg to
differ wait you can't leave me here to
be fair he can but i'm not sure why he
does if rick can bring morty with him
into the battery i'm not sure why he
couldn't bring summer as well in fact
rick knows that summer would be less of
a buzz kill so if anything why isn't he
leaving morty in the car if rick and the
gang are in a different reality who is
summer texting did we miss them getting
an interdimensional cell phone plan
added onto their interdimensional cable
package either way we're looking at one
sin for the show or one for [ __ ]
cable companies always trying to upsell
you on sh i know that the joke
throughout this episode is that the ship
follows rick's instructions to the
extreme but why would rick program it to
start with murder as its first line of
defense rick's an imaginative guy what
about electrifying the door or i don't
know having the ship move itself away
from the danger where are we rick morty
remember eight seconds ago and when you
said go inside what and i said the
battery and then we showed up here and i
wasn't like whoa this is unexpected this
is not what i was expecting morty as is
always the case rick would be excellent
at tv sins i put a spatially tessellated
void inside a modified temporal field
until a planet developed intelligent
life by this point i know the quest for
any semblance of meaning or logic behind
the science in rick and morty is a
fruitlessly frustrating one so to that
end i'm gonna save my sanity and time
and leave this with a very simple and
succinct how the [ __ ] can this possibly
work you have a whole planet sitting
around making your power for you that's
slavery it's society confusing the
inherent flaws that come with any modern
society with the actual [ __ ]
aberration that is slavery it appears we
are being revisited by the alien known
as rick who once gave our world the gift
of google box technology sinful news
position is sinful and all that but how
is this new story already being
broadcasted rick just got there and they
haven't actually seen him in person how
do they know someone else isn't flying
the discount board cube also why does
the newscaster have to explain what
google box technology is the
civilization is literally built to use
this technology who there wouldn't know
what a google box is do they need to
have one of these hooked up to every
household appliance and does that mean
that the appliance only works while the
stomping is in progress why don't they
have a way of storing the energy they
generate where the [ __ ] do these cables
go and why are they a different color
why is fluval gorks morty gotta flip
them off i told them it means peace
among worlds how hilarious is that as
hilarious as this prank is what's the
point it doesn't mean to these aliens
because they have no context for the
gesture's original meaning and it's not
like anyone is going to come visit the
universe held inside rick's ship battery
just to appreciate this flipping off of
an entire civilization consequence free
i bet there are plenty of [ __ ] that
would pay good money to do that
including me either way someone deserves
a sin i would love to see it [ __ ] you
who did you say to me
you
you told me it means much obliged how
has much obliged a suitable response to
rick wanting to see this genius
invention shouldn't he have said
something like happy to oblige unless
much obliged actually means happy to
oblige to these people in which case
[ __ ] you would it be possible for us to
get some kind of tour of your miniverse
from the inside why bother with a tour
just destroy the damn thing and make up
some bs about why they're forbidden to
create this technology again here's a
literal god to them this isn't a [ __ ]
chocolate factory i don't have time this
comment doesn't necessarily mean that
the wonkaverse exists in this entirely
unique and self-contained universe but
it does mean the chocolate exists and as
comforting as it is to discover that
chocolate appears to be a multiversal
constant it really doesn't make a damn
bit of sense so yes i'm sending
chocolate all right let's go
how did zerp flirterberg know that rick
would know to hold on to him and morty
for this to work and how [ __ ] quick
are rick's reactions there was zero
warning for this sudden transportation
what are you doing telling this guy that
his miniverse is unethical did do you
not see the hypocrisy here the only
thing i see is an implausible belief on
morty's behalf that rick isn't this
disingenuous and awful as a human being
hypocrisy indeed looked in a mirror
lately morty
[Music]
yet no one moves back crank it i told
them this means peace among worlds but
the gestures lip zlop is making actually
is the sign for peace in our universe at
least so does that mean this two-finger
gesture independently evolved to have
the opposite meaning in this microverse
culture thus allowing him to comically
assign it the inverse meaning in this
mini-verse which has actually meant its
reversion back to the original meaning
as we know in our universe are they not
really aliens no they're just a couple
of
crazy wacky scientists you know i hate
to be the well actually guy
[Laughter]
who am i kidding of course i don't
anyways from this perspective they're
all the very definition of aliens
pterodactyl
[ __ ] the only reason this exclamation
should have scared zlapp vanderflange is
if he's aware of what a pterodactyl is
which means this place also evolved
dinosaurs this would be a bizarre
mathematical impossibility even if it
were just another planet this is another
planet an entirely different universe i
guess the multiverse must really [ __ ]
love dinosaurs honestly you can't blame
them don't flatter yourself there's
always triple a you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i've heard the quantum battery add-on to
the aaa plan is priced very reasonably
what are we going to do now question
from the writers room when struggling
with this very weak b story somehow make
their way into the episode we are now
three layers of distinct universe deep
and the most variety this evolutionary
gene pool could muster is a third eye on
a deer this is still a [ __ ] deer i
don't know whether to send the fact that
this deer would have definitely heard
this timber-based jaeger situation
coming from a mile away and would have
long since bolted or the fact that this
[ __ ] tries to lunge for it instead of
using this [ __ ] boulder launcher to
kill it both it is
i hope your god is as big a dick as you
my god's the biggest dick that's never
existed blasphemy
[Music]
rick has formed for using snakes in this
way so i'm prepared to reluctantly buy
this element of his armory however the
cream of this carefully crafted pie of
bullshitter is that with this limited
amount of storage space zulu von stick
here chose to keep a [ __ ] eagle just
in case of this very eventuality and it
[ __ ] worked oh wow okay
that is pretty gay using the word gay as
an insult i masturbated to an extra
curvy piece of driftwood the other day
xylophiles oh hey guys i just finished
cooking us a feast the [ __ ] is there a
kitchen in this lab for also who would
want to live in a universe where one pan
of beige constitutes a feast
genocide a long time ago i implanted you
with the subdermal chip that could call
upon dormant nanobots in your
bloodstream to restructure your anatomy
and turn you into a car turning your
grandson into a turbo teen without
explicit consent
rick's eyes survive this
um guys
what happens if the hood is locked ew
what the hell jesus there's flies in my
ice cream fly scream
you are the ones who are the ball
lickers
the best ice cream in the multiverse
i thought about our dilemma and i came
up with a solution that i honestly think
works out best for one of both of us
that just sounds like slavery with extra
steps we live in a society we're honor
to distant memory
now slap on these antennae these people
need to think we're aliens right right
somebody said alien she thought they
said illegal aliens signed up nothing
you do matters your existence is a lie
you two
[Music]
the incredible turbo team
[Music]